KEVIN MOORE: This is me.
You can find me on
Google+ and Twitter.
I'm also kevmoo at GitHub.
So if you want to-- I've
referenced some sites,
some code there during my talk.
And so that's a good
place to follow and see
what I'm working on,
what I'm contributing to.
I'm here to talk about Dart.
I'm actually really excited
to be here talking about Dart.
The first I/O I came
to was last year.
And I was here as a
fanboy, a Dart fanboy,
to cheer on the
team, as they talked
about how great the
launch was going to be.
And I was really
excited about Dart.
In my development
career, I've done C,
C++ and Java and
C Sharp, and XAML.
And I've done Flash, and
I've done Silverlight,
and I've done
JavaScript and Ruby.
And I can say that in
both places I struggled.
I never found an experience
that really made me happy,
that gave me a great
development flow, while being
on the open web.
And not limited to
one operating system,
not because I have
some plug-in installed,
but the whole open web.
And so I discovered Dart,
and I was enamored by Dart,
and I started
contributing to Dart.
In December I went full-time
at Google to work on Dart.
And I'm excited to be here to
talk about it, and specifically
that developer experience--
or I'll just shorten to DX.
This is something really
important, and something
we really strive for
on the Dart team,
to deliver an amazing
developer experience
for people that want to
build on the open web.
So when I say DX,
what do I mean?
Well, I'll make
an analogy to UI.
And I put it in old-timey
font on purpose, right?
I spent a lot of
time when I first
started working in
software dealing with UI,
and talking about UI-- oh,
let's make the UI look cool!
Let's make it look pretty!
If you ever wanted to
get beat by a designer,
first thing is Comic Sans.
That's always the first
one they'll beat you.
But right below
that was asking them
to go make something pretty,
make it look more cool.
Right?
Because any good
designer will tell you
it's not about the pixels.
It's not just about making it
look pretty or cool, right?
It's about the experience.
And so by analogy--
when we talk about
experience, what does that mean?
It's more than pixels.
It's about being intuitive
or enjoyable-- hopefully
at the end of the
day, productive.
And so by analogy, we're going
to talk about a developer
experience in the same way.
It's more than syntax
or color coding
or some kind of tool
framework or test framework.
it's about having an
end-to-end experience that
helps you be productive
as a developer.
In the Dart team, we talk a lot
about the trifecta-- language,
tools, and libraries.
And I'll show
several demos today
to talk through
that set of stuff.
And I'd actually claim that
we've seen this story before,
done well.
Microsoft and Apple
and even Google
have shipped this experience
as great end-to-end.
The issue is the web.
In some ways, some might
argue is a little lacking.
And that's where Dart comes in.
The goal of Dart is to offer an
end-to-end developer experience
for the web.
Today I'm going to
talk about that.
I'm going to talk
to you about it
in terms of a spectrum,
an end-to-end spectrum.
We start with Dart as a
basis for just a great way
to write code that
targets the web.
To efficiently write code,
it's well-componentized
that's easy to understand.
It's easy to share.
It's easy to reuse.
On top of that, we have Polymer.
So what Dart does
for code, Polymer
does for the user experience
of your web applications,
and how Dart and
Polymer work together,
specifically adding on the
interesting announcements
today about paper
and material design.
And then on two ends of the
spectrum, we have mobile
and we have cloud.
So first I'm going to give
some context, because I'll
be talking about a very
contrived scenario today.
There's this little contact app.
So I have my Nexus
7 device here.
And I want to add
in a contact here.
Let's do John Moore.
Because today is his birthday.
So this is my birthday
shout-out to John.
And you can see I'm
using material design,
a set of components there
and just sit here and check
the check box all day long,
because it looks so cool.
And let's save that.
So I've created a new contact.
So, yes, this is pretty cool.
I'm not a designer.
And actually, later in the talk
I'll talk a little bit more
about how the tools
we're offering hopefully
will make this split
a little easier.
And so for folks
that you work with,
or maybe you yourself that
are really design-focused
have more freedom and can
get more done in this world.
Let's go back to slides.
So let's start
talking about Dart
as this basis for
this end-to-end.
There's many ways
to solve problems.
We can do the spaghetti way I've
certainly been guilty of this.
Now obviously, given any
framework, any set of tools,
you can decide not to
do the spaghetti way.
But having good tools
can really be helpful.
If you have the right
processors up front, but also
the right
infrastructure in place,
it actually can make
it a pit of success,
like doing the
right thing, doing
the clean thing can
actually just happen
if you have right
tools to help you out.
So what's our wish list
when we think about coding?
I would think
about three things.
One is, give us some
default structure
to get things started.
Second is, have
the tools actually
be smart and
understand our code,
and see what great
things can happen.
And finally is integration--
having everything
work well together.
So let's do a brief introduction
to Dart and talk about some
of these things.
Don't copy my password.
So let's look at
a piece of code.
Can everybody see the code OK?
Thumbs up in the back?
So here's the silliest "Hello,
world" example in Dart.
And it's designed for the web.
So you see that we
have a main method.
So right off the bat,
this is something simple.
So this is a web app.
You see I'm running
to the document
and just appending text.
We're going back to 1998 now for
our web app, at least to start.
So the first thing you'll see
is, we have a main method.
So there's a single
entry point if you're
building an app in Dart.
There's no document.ready
dance, when does it work,
you just write "main" and we'll
call "main" when you're ready.
Already it's really nice.
You'll see that we
can define classes.
So I just find a
contact class here.
And have a set of
fields, name and notes,
and then this
notion of important,
and I'm setting some values.
And already we have
this nice little syntax,
so that if you want to set
multiple fields and object,
you can just use dot dot.
It works really well.
And then we append
that to the document.
So right off the bat, I
want to point something out.
You might see this
little squiggle here.
Unused import.
So already, because Dart's
a structured language,
our tools can actually
understand the code
and understand what you're
doing in code and help you out.
So this is a very
simple example,
which is, like, I'm not
using this convert library.
So let's delete that.
Now in this case, it's
pretty trivial, right?
But if you wanted to track
the progression of your code,
if you're going to
manage your dependencies,
having a good idea of the
packages and libraries you're
using in your code
and being told
when you stop using
something is great.
That means you can update
your dependency matrix
and simplify your code.
But obviously if
you try to use code
without importing
the right dependency,
you find out right away.
So I'm doing all this
without running anything.
The tools can just tell me
because of the structure
of Dart and the
analyzer we have.
So let's go in a
little bit deeper.
So I see now, let's imagine
that the implementers
of main and the
implementer of contact
were two different developers.
For some reason,
this person decided
to assign the name
variable to be an array.
That wasn't my intention
as the contact developer.
I actually wanted
it to be a string.
How do I enforce that?
Of course this is very easy.
I just come in here and say
this should be a string.
That solves all our
problems, right?
Everyone reads code comments.
Clearly this works well.
So this is the
first step, right?
There's lots of debate about,
I don't want to type my code,
is it really necessary, does
it just add cruft to the code?
So here's my argument.
At a minimum as a
developer, you should
be doing this,
beyond a trivial app.
Even if you're the only
developer on your app,
like three months
from now you'll
forget what you were doing.
So at a minimum,
you should do this.
The question is,
what's the difference
in terms of how you code
from that, just doing this?
You're actually typing
less characters.
You can actually generate
documentation now,
based on this class, because
you attribute it using Dart.
And now the analyzer wakes
up, and says, oh by the way,
you can't assign an
array to a stream.
So let's do John here.
And so the same thing
with, let's say, notes.
Let's make sure that's a string.
Important-- let's make
sure that's a bool.
And these are examples
that are really important.
When we talk about
JSON serialization,
there's actually
a big difference
between the string true and
the literal true-- and actually
more importantly if
you're dealing with JSON,
the string false and the
literal false, right?
So being able to have these
annotated in your code
is really helpful.
And you'll notice that
I do a 2-string here.
Let's say as an
example, maybe I wanted
to return 42 for
my 2-string, right?
That seems legal.
But actually a 2-string
is an inherited method
from the base class.
Everything's an object.
So if you can mouse over
here, you actually see a hint.
This is overriding
in very small font.
object.2 string.
Well, let's debate.
I'm returning a 42.
Let's make this an integer.
And again, my system
yells at me and says,
the return type from the
base class is string.
So even when you think
about inheritance,
Dart helps you out, and
makes sure that if you change
the underlying contract, those
that implement your underlying
contract will get
warrant, whether you're
missing an implementation
or you type it incorrectly.
So let's make this a
string, like it should be.
We'll notice we
get another error,
because now our 42 is
not a string, clearly.
And the other thing
is, you'll notice
we have some nice
little add-ons.
For instance, we actually
support string interpolation.
And let's fix this guy.
And we'll run it.
So, happy birthday, brother.
Let me move this over
just a little bit.
So you'll see that I'm
running Chromium here.
It's actually not-- you actually
can't see I'm running Chromium.
Someone in IT's going
to get in trouble.
I'm actually running
Chrome called
Chromium, version of Chrome.
This is not normal Chrome.
Actually, we lovingly
refer to it as Dartium
This is actually a
version of Chrome
that ships with our SDK
that runs Dart natively.
What does this mean?
So there's obviously a lot
of languages and platforms
that let you write
other languages
and compile the
JavaScript, which is great.
The problem with
that is you have
to do a compile step
often, before you actually
run the code in the browser.
And then when you're
debugging issues,
you're debugging the JavaScript.
Now source maps gets you a
little far along the way.
But wouldn't it be nice to
just debug in the language
you're working in?
So I can come in
here and say throw
something silly and reload it.
And you'll see I
get break points
and I jump right
into the editor.
So that's Dartium.
we actually have
the Dart VM baked
in for development
in a custom browser.
Now beyond that, you'll see I'm
actually running a server here.
Right?
I'm hitting port 8080.
Underneath this is a
service we call pub serve.
But this handles not
only serving your assets
as you're building,
but also smart,
and knows what browser's
hitting the endpoint.
So if I hit it with an
endpoint that's not Dartium,
for instance,
Chrome, it actually
goes through with the work
and compiles the applications.
So now it's turning that
Dart code into JavaScript.
And you now see, it works
great in normal Chrome as well.
So what do we have?
First we're talking
about Dart analyzer.
This is the ability that our
tools understand our code.
This is actually
a standalone app
you can run outside the
editor if you want to,
and integrate it
in your own tools.
But it actually understands
the structure of your code.
And it lets you find errors
before you even run things.
We have pub serve.
This is our internal
server that understands
how to serve normal Dart code.
And then if you hit it with
another type of browser,
for instance, Chrome or
Firefox or anything else,
we spin up Dart to JS,
which is our compiler that
turns Dart code into JavaScript.
And of course this is
all wrapped up really
nicely in the Dart Editor.
We talked about Dartium.
This is a custom
build of Chromium
that ships as part of the
editor that has the Dart VM
baked in, and makes it easy to
debug the code you're writing.
So you can iterate quickly, get
most of the things ironed out
and then go test it on
deployed browsers and the web.
So you debug and
develop in Dartium,
and then you deploy
across any browser.
So that's part of the spectrum.
Let's talk about UI
here, obviously printing
my brother's name, as much
as I'm sure he appreciates
is not a great experience.
There's this
misconception that you
can't do rich UX on the web.
Obviously, with all the
talk about Android at I/O,
it's easy to forget that the
browser has come a long way.
Usually when you think about
running a mobile mapping,
we think about running the app.
The web app actually
works amazingly well.
Pinch and zoom works great,
rotation works great.
Like, we can build
rich UX for the web,
and it works really
well, even on mobile.
So yay, Rich UX!
The question now is, do we have
a rational developer experience
for building this rich UX?
So let's use an
example by analogy.
Datagrid-- if people have done
[? line-up ?] business apps,
everyone's like, I
need the Datagrid.
Always the Datagrid.
The first thing
you install, right?
So how do you do
datagrid on the web?
This, right?
That's our datagrid.
But it's not that, right?
You need to import
the right script tag,
and define the right CSS.
Then you need to define the div.
And it's probably
more than one class.
It might be many classes.
You might need to find
elements underneath it.
There's a lot of ceremony
to get this working, right?
You kind of end up with this.
You have styles
that leak all over,
and you're not sure
what's defined.
You can't define
it in one place.
It could be a huge mess.
So I claim this is not a
rational developer experience
for building components or
using components on the web.
What is the rational experience?
Do we have an existence proof?
And I would claim we do.
Whether you're doing C#
or Java or Xcode in iOS,
you define a component
and you extend,
using object inheritance,
a base component.
And things come along
that way, right?
And we've seen this
in other platforms.
So the web model, this
rational model for UX, is this.
Actually be able to
define my own element,
just like I do in
any other UI platform
and crank along that way.
So thankfully, our
friends the W3C,
with help from a
few browser vendors,
we have the standards
in place now
to have this great
experience as a developer.
We have Shadow DOM and
Template and Custom Element.
So this is in Firefox.
This is in Chrome.
We're doing work
with other vendors
to get this in all
other browsers.
And what's great is we
actually polyfill it
for those browsers that
don't support it yet.
And our friends on the
Polymer team, part of Chrome,
have done work to make a
rational developer experience
on top of these standards.
So have people heard of Polymer,
or seen the talks, right?
Amazing stuff for building
components on the web.
And today, we are excited
to announce material design.
This is a model for building
rich user experiences,
and a model for how
these user experiences
should look and
feel across devices.
Of course, Polymer
has just announced--
the Polymer team just
announced Paper Elements.
These are implementations of
the material design pattern
that have support in Polymer.
So what's our wish list
for these UX model, right?
One is, give us the
structure again.
So just like Dart gives you
structure for your code,
you want the same
structure in your UI.
And then you want it to be
easy to make these components.
You want it to be easy
to use these components,
and have it easy to
share these components.
So let's take a look.
And [? Sigi's ?] talking to me.
Oh, [? Sigi. ?] Just one second.
So we have an app here.
Our contacts app.
Let me move the window
over just a little bit.
Does that work OK?
Yell at me if you can't
see anything, please.
So this is our contacts app.
We actually have
an implementation
of our little context
class in here.
Actually, let's go open that up.
So this should look
pretty familiar.
We've added an ID field.
We've added a constructor.
And we've done a little bit
of work to understand JSON.
And that's about it.
So if you look at
our web directory,
you'll notice there's
actually no Dart code here.
It's all encapsulated
in the HTML.
And what' the HTML look like?
Let's look at the
structure of our app.
We have an app element.
This is kind of the
meat and potatoes
of the application
that does things.
And you have this
little sync service.
And this is actually
defined as an element.
And why this is interesting and
important, I'll get to later.
But I define an ID sync service.
And then I grab a hold of it
with the app element and say,
this is the ID of the thing
that does syncing for you.
So let's go look at that local
sync store implementation.
First, the element
definition is trivial.
There's actually
no UI here at all.
And you'll see that I
have a local sync store.
Now before I dive into those
details of this implementation,
you'll see that I'm implementing
a class, an interface-- sync.
Let's open that.
Now just that, I want
to show that already.
This is not, like, fuzzy,
word wheel search or grepping.
Like, I know what
the structure is.
I know where that
sync definition is.
I could have 50 definitions
of sync in this class,
or this project.
But I know what implementation
of sync I'm talking about.
I can just open the definition.
So you see I've defined
an abstract class.
This is the interface for sync.
If someone wants to
support syncing contacts
in my little contact app,
this is what they implement.
Now you don't care if this is
implemented as a UI component,
if it stores it in
the browser cache.
In my case, I'm
using local storage,
which Seth told me this morning.
I shouldn't be.
It should all be
in index DB so he
can go implement this
interface and use index DB,
and do it the right way.
By default, I have
an implementation.
But it's a very simple model.
And we can dig in more if
you're new to Dart to understand
our async model,
and our list model,
and our support for generics.
We won't go into that now.
So I have my little
local sync service.
And the other half of my
application is my app element.
So how does that look?
So the app element
is in two parts--
its code and its markup.
The markup's very
straightforward.
I define a Polymer element.
I give it a name.
I define some styles.
And then I do a bunch
of interesting things.
One is, I bring in
another element.
So I define a custom
context edit element.
I can handle events on this
element, by just doing On Save,
and passing in a method.
I can repeat over
properties on my class
and say, go through
all the contacts
and iterate and create a
bunch of contact items.
And then I define
the script backing.
If we look at the
script backing this,
you'll see that I'm doing
exactly what we talked about.
I define an app element, and I'm
extending the polymer element.
This is all supported
in Dart today.
So you can see, I can bind to--
I can set the app element
and actually bind to it,
so that that iteration
works really well.
I can define a method that
says, when saved just click
on my edit element.
Call this method.
And I can extract
a contact out of it
and call save on
my sync service.
So I have a clean model
for how I define my UI.
All in markup.
I can use binding to
reference properties
on my underlying object.
And I implement that using
types and all the great stuff
in Dart, using a class.
If you dig deep enough
into my elements--
you see edit is
an example here--
you'll see that I actually
use a bunch of Paper Elements.
So my fun check box,
that I can't help
but checking a bunch, because
the animation's so cool, right?
I just import that
in my element.
I say go get check box here.
Of course, check box
is a bunch of stuff.
It has shadows.
It has cool animation effects.
It has CSS.
And all of that
just encapsulated.
All I worry about is
importing the element.
And then I can
just handle events.
So I say OK, I have my button.
When someone clicks on
this, call the Save action.
When someone clicks Cancel,
call the Cancel action.
None of these
dependencies leak through.
The dependency is defined
once, in one place.
Super easy to use.
And of course, I
can run it locally.
Here we're doing the work to
turn to the Polymer elements
and everything, generate the
Dart we need, and drum roll.
I swear, there's relativistic
time dilation on stage
when your demo's loading.
Come on.
I believe.
Let me try killing
off Dartium here.
Oh, I have another
instance open.
That might be it.
Let me do this.
Ah, the gods.
Give me one more second.
Make sure I'm not doing
anything silly here.
I don't think so.
Oh.
Well, you saw the app already.
Hopefully, the next stuff
will go a little bit better.
So way deep in my
elements, I have
my app, then my app element,
then my contact item,
and inside contact item
I have my paper element.
What's nice is, this inheritance
model that we're used to,
the object oriented
programming, plays here.
Every paper element
is a Polymer element.
Every Polymer element
is a custom element.
Every custom element
is just an element.
And we're excited today that
we've done work on the Dart
team to expose these 2U
as a Dart programmer.
So core elements
has already been out
and shipped by the Polymer team.
And the paper elements is now
available, shipped this morning
from the Polymer folks.
And we now have a package
available, hopefully soon,
that you can go install these
and use these on your own Dart
apps, starting today.
So let's go the other end
of the spectrum-- mobile.
So deploying across
browsers is great.
The problem is, if your
browser's only your desktop,
you're missing out.
We have a lot of other
devices on the web.
In fact, many
people have argued--
and actually, there's data
showing-- that this year
sometime, the amount of web
traffic from mobile devices
will exceed that
from desktop devices.
And we hear this mantra a lot.
In the keynote this
morning and other places--
mobile first, mobile
first, mobile first.
So how do we sell
this on our devices
if we're going to do
mobile web development?
We ship Chrome, a
custom build of Chrome,
for Android as part of
our development tools
that includes a Dart VM.
So you can debug Dart
code on a mobile device,
on your Android device, and have
a great development experience.
So what we're excited
to show you today
is, we now have this
Dartium, this custom
build of Dartium
that runs on Android.
We leverage the existing
tools that you already
use, if you guys use
Chrome Inspect to do
mobile development, you can
use those today with Dart.
And this is all baked
into the Dart Editor.
So let's show a demo.
Did you try turning it off
and turning it back on again?
We'll try that.
So you see that I have my
device plugged in here.
I'll show you the wolf.
This is proof that my
device is running here.
I'm hitting local
host on a device,
which doesn't make
a lot of sense.
So let's see how that works.
The first thing you do
is you open up Chrome.
Oops.
You'll see that, again, if
people played with the dev
tools in Chrome,
this already exists.
You can actually define--
connect to your device.
You set up debugging
on your Android device.
Set up port
forwarding, so we can
find those ports and
forward connections.
And now you can debug an
application on Android.
So now if we go in an
then we right-click and do
run on mobile, from our editor,
so we're spinning up pub serve,
like we usually do.
And now you'll see
what we're doing
is we're installing
content shell.
So we're actually
installing an application
on your Android
device, now that'
you've authorized it for debug.
And this content shell device
is this Dartium instance.
It actually is the
Dart VM built in.
So if we switch
over here, you see
I have the app running here.
I can go in and
create a new contact.
This is typing when
you're in a hurry.
What's great is you still the
same debugging experience.
So let's go into our little--
switching is always fun.
Let's go back to the--
let's go back to our app.
Maybe to our local data store.
Let's just randomly
throw somewhere.
Oops.
Let's complete our string.
Things that are
nice and upfront.
So if I add a contact, I
should get a throw here.
Let's go in now.
Add another contact.
Drum roll.
Oh, you can do it.
Give me one second.
The demo gods are
frowning upon me.
Let's try one more time.
Actually, instead of throwing
here, let's go into our app.
And when someone calls
save, let's throw here.
Great.
Let's reload the app.
That's probably what caused
the problem last time.
Go back to the podium.
It's creating a new contact.
Save.
You know it's at hung,
because we hit a break point.
And so this is all the
stuff you'd expect.
You can actually go in
and see the stack trace.
The fonts aren't
scaled very well here.
You see this stack trace,
and what was called.
You can see the
objects in scope.
And actually, I had a lot
of fun developing this.
I actually found myself
just using the device,
as I was coding.
And coding along, I hit
Refresh on the device,
and it just worked,
which is actually
we should be doing, right?
We should be coding on the
devices we're targeting.
And it's more and more mobile.
So we have a version of Dartium.
Again, this is a custom, debug
only version of Dartium design
that runs Dart VM.
We leverage the
existing Chrome tools.
It's all based on the Editor.
And it's available
today, with Dart 1.5.
So go install.
So that's one end.
Let's go all the way to
the other end-- the cloud.
So we talked a lot about
targeting browsers with Dart.
And actually that
was our main focus
when we started-- support
the open web, open browsers.
But it turns out, we've done
a lot of work on this VM.
And it'd be nice to use the
VM in places other than just
our debug tools in Dartium.
It actually turns out it's
very easy to write a Dart app.
You can just define that, which
works really well, and run it.
We ship a Dart command.
So we didn't wait for
node Dart to ship.
We figured we'd just
ship a command that
lets you run Dart
directly in the shell,
and execute Dart code directly.
And in fact, the things I
talked about today, Dart2js
or compiler or analyzer or
pub system or documentation
generator-- these are
all written in Dart.
And they're designed to run
independent of the browser.
So already in the Dart team
today, like our compiler
we're bootstrap Dart in Dart.
And we ship a
library that lets you
access to all the things
you want to access, right?
Directories and files, web
sockets, secure sockets,
htp serving, all the things
you want to do-- file watching.
You can go into this today.
Obviously, you can't use
these APIs in a browser app
anymore than you could use
button element in a server app.
We have access to these things.
And we've done a lot of work
to improve our performance.
In the last several
months, we've
already done work,
I think 6x increase,
in file serving scenarios.
So we've done a lot of work
to optimize these things.
It turns out you can actually
deploy server apps in Dart
today, on the Google Cloud
Platform, using Compute Engine.
I know, people, this isn't
exactly what you want,
but bear with me.
It's actually a great
way to go play with Dart
today on the server, or
anywhere that supports Docker.
So obviously, the cloud
folks have done a lot of work
to support Docker and actually
Docker came out a week ago
as a v1 release.
And as part of that, Google
announced that actually you
can deploy Docker
images much easier
now on Google Compute
infrastructure.
In fact, if you go searching for
Docker Google Cloud Platform--
the URL is a little
ugly-- you can
go see about deploying Docker
images on Google Cloud.
And it turns out,
it's really simple
to create images that
use Docker with Dart.
In fact, I have a sample here.
So if you're running
Docker on your laptop
now, even if you don't
have the Dart tools,
you can go run-- what is
it-- Docker run, kevmoo.
I have it registered.
And like, spin up a Dart
server on your local machine,
and actually test it out on
your laptop, all using Docker.
It's a great story, and we
play along there really nicely.
Of course, people want a
little bit more than that.
We've been hearing about
requests for app engine support
since Dart started, basically,
for lots of reasons, right?
You want a Dev Server.
So things like
Memcache and Data Store
you can run locally, and have
those local copies as you
iterate in your development.
And obviously,
there's great support
for monitoring and
management as well.
So the cloud folks
have done a great job
and recently announced-- I think
in March-- App Engine custom
run times.
This is the ability
for bring your own run
time to App Engine.
Right now it's in private beta.
You can't do this.
But the cloud team is working
actively to bring this out.
So you can run any
language or runtime
you want and have the same
access to the App Engine's
APIs.
And what we're excited
about today is,
I'll give you a sneak peek
of the support in Dart.
The Dart team is using the
support provided by the cloud
engine so that we provide an
App Engine experience using
Dart on Google's infrastructure.
So what do we have?
We have libraries.
We have an App Engine library,
a memcache and cloud_datastore.
Again, these aren't
public yet, so don't
go looking for them
in the pub repository.
But they're there.
And we're working on them.
And it turns out it's really
straightforward to use.
So you call runAppEngine
and you give it a handler.
This is a lambda definition.
And in that context you
can handle the requests.
You can access the data store,
memcached, or anything else.
The coding model's actually
really straightforward.
And so how does this
play with pub, right?
Because we have this
pub system running that
handles compiling your assets.
So we try to be smart here.
Basically, when a
request comes in,
if it's accessing
static content, things
you've defined in your web
directory, it gets run via pub
serve.
And then everything else it's
an executable you define.
And by convention, it's
usually in the bin directory
called server.
And then when we
deploy your app,
what we do is we do work
to build your assets,
actually create a static
copy of all the JavaScript
and everything else.
And then we serve
this to App Engine.
And so in that model you
get a static file handler
that handles all
the static assets.
And everything else
runs your code normally.
So you have a great
development experience
on your local machine
and when you deploy, you
get all your assets
compiled nicely
so it runs across any browser.
We've also done work
for the data model.
This is actually on a
model we're iterating on.
The idea is you
can define a class,
define a meta-model for it.
This is the shape of my class.
Set up a meta model to say
these are the types and things.
I'm hoping we can do
work here to actually
do some code generation
for you as well.
So because you've already
annotated your Greeting model
in this case, with
strings and dates,
we can just generate
the model for you
and just generate
the data store types.
And it just works.
So let's do a demo.
First, let me close
some things down.
So you see we have a server app.
You guys can see this OK?
First, we'll open
the web directory
because I want to show you this.
So the project name
is contacts_server.
What you'll notice is, I've
actually imported the contacts
app that I just defined earlier.
So I had a contacts
app, and it had
custom elements in
the sync adapter.
I'm importing that
into this project.
I'm actually
depending on it here.
So if you look at the HTML
file defined in my server,
I'm defining the
same app element
and saying go get
your sync element.
And here's the difference.
Instead of using the poorly
implemented local storage
implementation for sync, I
have a cloud sync adapter.
And I define that
in this project.
So let's go look at cloud
sync, because everything else
runs the exact same way.
In fact, I'll take a moment
to actually make this point.
What's nice is, components
are just like libraries.
You can define
them in a package,
you can re-use them
in another package.
So this is a great
model for separation.
You can imagine
giving your front end
guy this package with
a little local store
and say, go make the UI pretty.
Ha.
And then he'll beat
you with Comic Sans.
Gp make the UI
interesting and great
and a great user
experience, and I'll
go work on the server stuff.
And you know that if you change
the sync interface or anything
else, the tools will tell
you and help you along.
So you have an
implementation of-- oops,
go on here-- a sync adapter.
Implement sync again.
It's a Polymer element.
And this time, instead of
talking to the local storage,
I actually say, post
JSON and get JSON
using our web request model.
So now I'm doing XHR and
this client provider.
This is all code that
runs on the client.
And actually go access the
endpoint API slash contacts.
So I'm doing gets against that,
I'm doing post against that.
This is all still browser code.
So we know what the browser
code looks like, right?
So what's running on the server?
We talk about all the
stuff [? that will be ?]
served to the client.
On the server side, we've
defined a server binary
in our bin directory.
And at the end,
all we say here is
I have a little
wrapper that makes
building composable
applications easier.
I call it shelf.
I'm going to talk
about this tomorrow.
Come and find my talk
about shelf tomorrow.
But all I'm saying is
serve up this handler.
It's just a method.
So I have my little
handler method.
And this does work to break
up the URI into segments.
If the segment's
API, it calls off
to another handler I've defined.
We'll get into that later.
And otherwise.
it does some interesting
memcache stuff, just
to kind of show that it's there.
So let me go spin up my server.
You see it running
G cloud, app run.
We'll wait for
that to get going.
Listing on on port 8080.
I should pick a browser to use.
Let's do this one.
This is where we hope
for the demo gods.
There we go.
So Seth, demo time.
I'll add an item here.
And save.
Make sure editing
isn't happening here.
So what's happening here?
We have this data store handler.
And it turns out,
I have another API
that defines a handler
for data store.
And what I do here is I
say, you have endpoints.
In this case, there's
a context endpoint
and it maps to a JSON mapper.
This is a class I've defined.
What this handler
does is, because we
have rich types in
Dart, we can say hey,
for a list of
strings in this map,
take all these JSON
mappers and implement them
as API front ends,
for all the stuff.
So if I go to my app and I
go to API slash contacts,
you see that this is
returning the JSON.
So because we have
rich types in Dart,
I can do things like
define these mappers
and say, here's a
list of the endpoints
I want to support, with post for
populating and delete in get.
And it just defines
the endpoints.
And I write it once.
Now of course, this is just
getting started, right?
Because you want to implement
security and authentication
for these APIs.
But in terms of a model,
it's really straightforward.
And so the other
interesting thing is,
all this uses the
existing infrastructure
I defined before.
So you talk about
serializing the objects.
I'm using the two JSON from JSON
that I defined in the object.
All the same code applies here.
So I'm using the exact
same context type.
Let me open that up.
I take the
implementation of contact
that I defined in the other
application, and use it here.
And I extend it
with a model type.
And model is the
base type that's
used in data store This is
another convention in Dart--
the ability to actually
mix in classes.
So now that my DS contact
is the same kind of contact,
and I have to add
some constructors.
But otherwise, I'm re-using
the contact implementation
from the other library,
the exact same code that
runs in the browser.
It runs in the server now.
And I extend it
with a functionality
so it supports data store.
And of course, a data
store demo would not
be complete unless I go into the
App Engine Devs Server Manager.
I look at my data store.
I see I have Seth here.
Seth, go away.
And we see that Seth's gone now.
So again, this is the
App Engine customer run
time work is work being
done by the cloud team
to offer bring
your own run time.
So anyone can have
the same functionality
that exists currently in App
Engine with native languages,
currently in private beta.
They're working hard
to have a release.
Andrew said maybe this year.
I can't wait to play with it.
We're building on this
infrastructure that already
exists, to bring Dart to this
new world of custom run times.
Again, not ready yet--
we're working hard.
As soon as the cloud team has
custom run times available,
we'll be right there
with Dart implementation
so you can start playing.
And we're actually
hoping that all
of our implementation for
Dart, like the rest of the Dart
project, will be
completely open source.
So you can see how
we implement things.
You can send
patches to us if you
wanted to use data store
model in a different way.
We'd love help.
And if you go here,
there's a mailing list.
You can stay tuned for more
information about this project.
So that's cloud.
And that's our end-to-end.
The goal of Dart is having
this great end-to-end developer
experience.
Great way to find
code, integrates
with Polymer, which
is a great way
to find UI, which
implements paper, which
is a beautiful implementation
of UI components.
We go to mobile, give
you a great experience
to target mobile.
And we're looking
forward to giving you
a great experience
for server as well.
What's next?
Tomorrow morning, we
have a talk about Spark,
which is an IDE written in
Dart that runs on Chromebooks.
It's a Chrome app.
1/3 of the talk will all be
about Polymer and other things,
about building packaged
apps, Chrome apps, excuse me,
in Dart.
So please come to that.
To learn anything about what
we're working on on the Dart
team, please go to dartlang.org.
We're on Google+ at +dartlang,
@dartlang on Twitter,
and of course, hash
tags are all cool.
So tweet us if you
have questions.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]